a woman has today been convicted of
murdering a one-year-old she had been
planning to adopt authorities in cumbria
had placed leyland james corkill with
laura castle less than five months
before his death from catastrophic head
injuries it really is
a disturbing case let's speak to skies
fraser ward who is at preston crown
court um where that verdict was handed
down earlier a fraser if some of these
details are really upsetting so we
should just warn viewers but remind us
of some of the details involved here
that's right yeah layla and james
corkill was just 13 months old
when he died he'd been placed in the
care of laura and scott castle in in
barrow in cumbria they were hoping
there's at some stage they may
eventually be able to adopt him they
were looking after him effectively as as
foster parents but began to
struggle increasingly with coping uh
with with their young charge the the
court heard
text messages that have been written
between the two explaining some of the
incidents that had happened in one of
them laura laura castle said that she
had absolutely leathered him in another
she said that she wanted to smack him
but she was worried that if she started
smacking him she might not be able to
stop uh when he was first injured the
the emergency services came to the house
he was taken away with severe injuries
severe head injuries which laura castle
had said were caused when she'd stood up
to you suddenly and layla and james had
fallen from a lap and and onto the floor
hitting his head on the sofa as he fell
but medical officers medical staff at
alder hey hospital in liverpool thought
that the injuries were certainly not
consistent with just a single fall they
found that there was severe trauma to
the blood vessels in the eyes and in the
brain as well suggesting that that this
young toddler 13 months old had been
shaken very violently and it was only
whilst giving evidence that the truth
came out that laura castle did admit to
shaking young leyland james she was
frustrated he wouldn't stop crying she
began to shake him and it was then she
said that he hit his head on the sofa
initially she said it was an accident
when the trial started here she pleaded
guilty initially to causing the death of
young leyland james but pleaded not
guilty to his murder but after hearing
all the evidence medical evidence uh the
text messages
and so on the jury here took only around
two hours or so to decide that she was
in fact guilty of the of the young
child's murder
the text message is a key part of this
the medical examination is a key part of
it
as well but despite all of this despite
the fact that the medical examination
suggested that there had been longer
term problems longer-term abuse of young
leyland james there was no concern
amongst the social services it was
cumbria county council who placed lane
and james in the castle's care they made
regular weekly checks and at no stage
the court heard were any alarm bells
rung were any warning signs there it
seemed as though everything was going
reasonably smoothly so of course there
will now be an investigation into the
situation surrounding that there's going
to be a safeguarding report it's already
underway at cumbria county council
trying to find out exactly what mistakes
were made here why there weren't any
alarm bells why there were no warning
signs when clearly young leyland james
according to what we've heard in court
according to what the medical team said
uh had been suffering for some time but
the hands of a couple who literally
couldn't cope with his needs despite the
fact that he was only 13 months old just
a toddler so that review the
safeguarding review the results from
that are not due to be published
until at least july and in terms of the
sentence that uh that uh laura castle is
going to be handed down that will be
determined at a later date by the judge
so the judge is just uh working out when
sentencing can take place in terms of of
scott castle laura castle's husband
he maintained that he was unaware of the
mistreatment that he was upstairs when
the incident happened he wasn't aware of
exactly what had happened on the night
that uh that young leyland james was
fatally injured he faced charges of
allowing a person to die and another
charge of child cruelty he was found not
guilty on both those charges he was in
tears as he left the courtroom and when
he came out of court a short time ago
made no comment to any of the reporters
outside here he walks away a free man
laura castle will await to hear her fate
her her barrister illegal team have
already conceded that they realize that
a life sentence is going to be mandatory
given the guilty verdict on a charge of
murder and her own barrister said that
from now on she will always be known
as a baby killer as i say she waits to
hear the full extent of her sentence
it's likely that it will be a life term
but there may be mitigating or
aggravating factors which all which can
vary the actual length of term of that
life sentence so we'll wait to hear from
the judge when that sentence is going to
be passed down
fraser thank you such an upsetting case
thank you very much hannah with such
sensitivity frasier